Wyatt and Kurt Russell talking about
remaking the last star fighter yeah okay
the whole movie they're in this like
weird you know space thing but but I I
think that's a kind of they've tried to
remake that movie but I think the person
who's in charge of the IP will not let
it go welcome to Sidetrack your SciFi TV
and Movie Channel there was a movie
blanking on the name of it it's called
like Star overboard overboard
the Sci-Fi version overboard in
space it's Christmas jump day at work by
the way do you like it it's my it's my
Christmas cardi my wife hates this thing
but anyway let's get to the reason for
the video the last star fighter is a
film that is a bit of a cult classic and
one of the very earliest movies to use
really decent computer generated images
this and Tron really were the first
films to do it it had a budget of 15
million back then which is pretty
impressive and it really is a great
movie where the story of it is this kid
who plays this video game he's
unbelievable at this video game and then
the alien comes down and he needs to
save the universe by basically playing
the video game who would be in that
there there was a movie blanking on the
name of it it's called like Star
overboard overboard the Sci-Fi version
overboard in
space who would be in that movie will
you see Goldie HW overboard in
space it's a no um was it a movie yeah
it was about a kid who lives in a
trailer park and he plays a video game
was he's the director of that movie is
one of John carp you you should know
this you're you're St last star star
fighter last star fighter last star
fighter is a totally flawed film I
remember seeing that like flawed because
well I liked it okay maybe not flawed as
much as it is just underdone like oh in
other words there's a lot more there
there's a lot more there that you can do
now where the story of it is this kid
who plays this video game he's
unbelievable at this video game and then
the alien comes down and he needs to
save the universe by basically playing
the video game who's the director of
that Dan Don it's Nick Castle Nick
castle Yeah Nick was Nick was one of the
worked with John on skap from New York
now there has been a big Push by
Universal Studios to try and get a
sequel um the last star five TS has been
bounced around for quite some time um as
far as going actually that the director
and producer involved actually produced
this sort of like fake trailer to try
and get a bit of uh momentum
[Music]
going
so what is happening where are we now
well I've been able to speak to one of
my sources immediately basically he
confirms what white is talking about
here that the IP has really been a bit
bogged down with sort of legal Universal
are desperately trying to get some sort
of solution but it's really get get
stuck in development hell as so many
movies do it ALS so then didn't help the
things like the strikes happened which
really put a lot of projects on the back
burner so as we speak right now there
are no direct plans for a last star
Fighters movie but Universal is still
very interested so it is interesting
when an up andc coming actor like Wyatt
Russell talks about it and maybe you
could get your dad involved that would
be okay you know use the name why not
Paul fcker told me to watch that movie
it's good it's a good movie it could be
redone especially if you give more than
$750 to make it with I me now you can
make that and build out the space world
I actually think coming off Monarch
Wyatt is going to well his star is
rising basically and if there are
projects like this he wants to get
involved in that really does add a
little bit of weight to the possibility
last star fighter is a totally flawed
film I remember seeing that like flawed
because I it okay maybe not flawed as
much as it is just underdone like oh in
other words there's a lot more there
there's a lot more there that you can do
now I actually agree with white here
that this film was not underwhelming it
was
underused you see a film like this and
you just think wow imagine this bigger
you know there's only one star fighter
the last star fighter there's just one
base on that planet with a couple of
star Fighters there's one enemy vessel
with a couple of dozen um you know like
drones or
Fighters it didn't really make a lot of
sense if you actually think about it if
this was real but the whole storyline
about this computer game being sent out
there and being used as a recruitment
tool was actually very clever and I'd
love to see that done in a modern sense
particularly you know if you think about
like social media or something it could
be done a little bit differently now
with technology the way it is
unfortunately it wouldn't be a classic
arcade machine anymore sad these to like
arcade machines they cost a fortune
nowadays so it's like two quid for a
game it last 3 seconds anyway I'm old
these things wind me up so I actually
think the modern culture and modern
audience would be ready for a game like
this all the kids playing on their
computer games fantasizing about being
able to take on an enemy in real life
like that but also the CGI etc's come on
so far you wouldn't even have to spend a
massive amount of money well relatively
to actually produce something that was
very cool particularly if you include a
bunch of actors that nobody knows don't
spend $3 million just getting one A-list
actor put the money on the screen you
know and they could produce something
really really cool and most importantly
a sequel let's do the last star Fighters
let's not do a remake because the
original deserves the credit you know it
deserves to still exist within this
universe let's add to it because I
actually think Wyatt is bang on that
this is a movie that does deserve more
and Kurt Russell obviously knows how
good a film this was even if he couldn't
remember what it was called and he
couldn't remember the director's name
even though he'd worked with him but
anyway guys get into the coms going and
tell me what you think is this a movie
would kill to see get a sequel or a
remake I prefer a sequel but get into
the comments and tell me what you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com sidre
where most of our new videos Premier
first and you get to see them without
the adverts also you can go to s.co
which is our dedicated website where we
do stories based on most of our videos
and we try to add a little bit more meat
you to digest go and check it out Merry
Christmas and if it's your Christmas
jumper day don't forget to give to
charity uh my charity over here is save
the children so or children in need or
something like that there's children
they'll get money off me they should say
thank you all of them but they don't
children anyway stay safe and I'll see
you next
time